estadios imponentes pero vacíos esa es
la principal postal que deja la primera
los primeros días de la copa africana de
naciones en camerún salvo por el partido
inaugural y el choque entre nigeria y
egipto no ha habido grandes afluencias
de público a los estadios ni siquiera en
el último encuentro de cambiar una
entente ante etiopía una de las
principales razones son los protocolos
estrictos que han dispuesto a las
autoridades para el ingreso a los
estadios que incluyen la vacunación y la
realización de pruebas contra el cob y
19 previas a los encuentros los
campeones son reticentes a aplicarse la
vacuna y por tanto aunque se ha dado
cierto impulso a la campaña con la copa
africana de naciones esto no ha sido
suficiente para hacerles cambiar de
opinión el otro gran punto a tener en
cuenta es el coste de las entradas que
se ubican entre unos tres mil y ocho mil
francos ccfa es decir entre cuatro y
doce euros una cifra bastante elevada y
que irá creciendo a medida que avanza el
torneo demasiado para un país en el que
el salario mínimo mínimo se ubica por
debajo de los sesenta euros es una
situación que preocupa a las autoridades
y que ha llevado incluso al gobierno a
lanzar un comunicado a través de su
ministerio de comunicación impulsando a
las personas asistir a los partidos de
todas las selecciones mientras que
gobiernos regionales están evaluando
medidas para acercar al público a los
estadios